nicht dass es in berlin zu wenig
straßenschilder gäbe aber die
platanenstraße im bezirk pankow ist
absolut rekordverdächtig
an fast jedem baum an fast jedem
bordstein steht ein solches schild
gefühlt wurde hier die jahresproduktion
des verkehrszeichens vorgeschriebene
vorbeifahrt verbaut
insgesamt sage und schreibe 46 stück auf
ein paar hundert metern
ich finds idiotisch ich habe so etwas
noch nie gesehen
es gibt so viele es einmal
steuerverschwendung neue und fragt sich
was da gibt es einfach genug dafür
einfach nur bekloppt vor zwei jahren
wird die platanenstraße saniert der alte
belag kommt runter dafür gibt's neuen
asphalt am rand baut die stadt
parkbuchten um die altehrwürdigen bäume
zu schützen werden diese beete angelegt
samt bordsteinen so weit so gut aber
dann beginnt der pankower schilder waren
denn an fast jeder ecke vor fast jeden
baum stellt das bezirksamt diese
schilder kosten knapp 6700 euro
das zeichen soll den verkehr eigentlich
an gefahrenquellen vorbei leiten
aber wo bitte schön soll hier eine
gefahr seien
auf der platanenstraße kann man nur
stumpf geradeausfahren das sollte doch
jeder verkehrsteilnehmer mit
führerschein schaffen ist ja so ein
bisschen die frage nach dem gewissen
gesunden menschenverstand auch ja also
nicht nur nach dem führerschein
ich finde es unnötig vor allem wenn man
sieht zum beispiel den schulen wie
marode die sind da hätte man dort das
geld einfach einstecken können
aber das zuständige bezirksamt
verteidigt den schilderwald in der
platanenstraße schriftlich heißt es der
straßenbaulastträger hat hier diese
entscheidung getroffen um die nach der
sanierung eingetretene neue bauliche
situation den verkehrsteilnehmern zu
verdeutlichen die wiederholung der
beschilderung soll hier zur
verdeutlichung der situation beitragen
eine wiederholung zur verdeutlichung aha
die berliner finden das absolut
überflüssig
nun hofft dass schon dank gefahren die
schilder braucht man wirklich nicht das
ist nach meiner anfänger prüfung für den
führerschein ist sowieso zone 30 wird
jetzt keiner so langen brettern dass er
das nicht sehen kann
6700 euro für 46 überflüssige schilder
geld das man in der dauerbaustelle
berlin sicher besser hätte einsetzen
können